the other accusation you faced or which
is they've said a lot is the people
connected with Russia or backed by
Russia were the people who hacked into
the Democratic Party's database that you
would also say is completely untrue yeah
but in juniors loan no I don't know
anything about that a cracker if you
wouldn't you know how many hackers there
are today
Hilla granny and X so delicately and
precisely then what because that they
can leave their mark at the necessary
time in place or even not their role in
mark camouflage activity as our Father
hackers from other territories or
countries the UK Tory is the gift run at
the back I need it's an extremely
difficult thing to change if it's even
possible to check at any rate we
definitely do not do this at the state
level isn't isn't it time that we all
wish to be a part of it and then we see
the version is that really important
Lama Tom I would it you know keep Adam
doesn't even matter who hacked this data
from the campaign had qualitative
Clinton was not Steve lettuce is
Wrangham the worst of all pregabalin and
the important thing is the content that
was given the proper cook yes question
there should be discussion about this
and there is no need to distract the
public's attention to the essence of the
problem but by using some styling she's
connecting me answers roughly didn't see
as many as poised come to walk to it is
do what you want surance called me about
the tuition fusion which we but I want
to tell you again I didn't know anything
like a day and on the state level
Russian every analyst mimics to be a
plea today it was Cal McRaven sleeper
matter party to be good I couldn't even
match Davis I didn't emission is
interesting to American society I've got
with specifically that I campaign
headquarters worked in the interests of
one of the candidates in this case we're
about only you in this case mrs. Clinton
you're rather not qualify on the
Democratic you can do that mr. Park so
even from this point to agree we could
have officially penetrated it right
there on extent which is doing me new
Kappas and Excel
you understand to deck into it you
understand that you have a finger on the
plastic existed yeah you understand to
do that you need to have a finger on the
plus and get the specifics of domestic
political life in the u.s. I'm not sure
that you're even our foreign ministry
experts are sensitive enough to do you
know think do you not think that this is
sort of time when everyone should sort
of come clean about it you know Russia
tries to hack America America tries to
hack Russia China tries to hack America
China tries to hack Russia everyone
tries to hack each other that one of the
purposes of the g20 is to come up with a
new set of rules so that this can become
a more ordered version of foreign policy
when everybody is doing it allegedly I
think that it would be better for the
g20 not to get involved because there
are other venues of this did the g20 was
feeling it as a platform to discuss
issues mainly concerning the global
economy if we're going to load it up
because politics engines economic
process that's a clear fact I think we
add some squabbles or even not squabbles
got very serious issues that relate
purely to world politics then we will
all well the g20 agenda dr. leo and then
instead of working on issues of finance
structural changes to the economy
taxation and so on in place of that will
endlessly argue about serious problems
or some other world problems and there
are plenty and we'll talk about the
Middle East
it's better to find other venues and
other forums and there are playing sir
on the UN Security Council for example